[Music]
hello to all viewers welcome back to
next episode of what's up Roth hello
Walter hi are you doing
nah we're kicking stole we had a
tumultuous week yes and we're gonna
discuss a bit of that
please open for us with a word of Prayer
our loving Heavenly Father there are so
many issues in the world today that
clamour for our attention but we have a
specific message and the time for
presenting that message is slowly
running out and Lord we feel an urgency
to bring the message so that people can
be forewarned of what is coming upon the
earth and as we discuss this issue now I
pray that you will be with us that you
will be without the Liberation's that
you will give us clarity of mind and
that you will through your Holy Spirit
enlighten us and enlighten those that
are listening in Jesus name Amen
me so you feet a wasp's nest with the
presentation a raw nerve or nerve
yes and I've we've had a wave of
comments and people trying to say
something that they think you said and
Miss understanding and putting words in
your mouth sometimes and then I think
mostly misunderstanding what you
actually said would you briefly discuss
before we begin the study on what was
the is this the end lecture about the
lecture is this the end has two
components the one component is where
are we in the stream of time according
to the signs of the times
and that that is a standalone portion
the the aim is to show the nearness of
time now I've spoken to so many people
and so many people were even within the
church that say the Lord's coming cannot
be that near there are too many issues
that must all fall into place and we
don't believe that the coming of the
Lord is for another hundred years maybe
two hundred years maybe another thousand
years we don't know there are people
that are saying that the prophecies
regarding let's say Revelation chapter
13 that those are conditional and that
the systems that are discussed in those
churches are not the same as they were
before they've changed so these things
might never happen and when I see the
signs of the times fulfilling I have an
urgency to tell people wake up the time
is at hand
and so they claim there is still plenty
of time after all the gospel must still
go to the whole world how are you going
to reach the whole world today with the
communications that we have this is this
is something that can be achieved
so my first aim is to show the urgency
of the matter the second portion dealt
with the great week of time and what the
Pioneers believed and then of course is
apart from prophecy and it has a
specific time which is 6,000 years for
this world
and another 1,000 years for the
Millennium but that is not prophetic
time and we can talk about that and it
and it has a date and we can discuss
that as we continue so my aim was to
show the nearness of time I don't know
how many times in the lecture I said I
am NOT making a specific time and even
if you can
calculate the specific time it can be
cut short or it can be lengthened so I
never made a specific time my crime was
that I had a date if you look at the
6000 years then it is of course possible
to come to a specific time but that
doesn't mean that that time is when the
end will take place because it can be
cut short or the Lord can delay his
coming whether he comes in the first
watch whether he comes in the second
watch whether he comes in the third
watch that's not my business and the
time is also that we the the time that
you said is not for the coming of Jesus
no it was what if you use these
calculations what time will you come to
so let us talk about some of these
issues yeah I think we can discuss it
and it will be wonderful
if the viewers will also look at this in
depth with us we don't want to enforce
anything this is ideas yeah that you've
got absolutely some information you've
gotten together and nobody is forced to
believe in the cosmic week nobody is
forced to believe in anything because
you have a freedom of choice but if
there are certain historic parameters
that we can put on the table then surely
they can be discussed whether you want
to accept them or not that is a personal
issue and I would like to for my
personal standpoint say that if Jesus
comes within the next year or in the
next 50 years it doesn't matter to me I
will preach the three angels message
with the same fervor until I raised my
head absolutely let's have a look at
what is working and how we can address
this issue the great problem is really
with regard to the great cosmic week and
this is one of the slides that we had in
the previous lecture where the text in
Psalms and Peter
is there which says that let's read
second Peter 3 verse 8 but beloved be
not ignorant of this one thing that one
day is with the Lord as a thousand years
and a thousand years as one day and then
in the book of Revelation you have the
references to the thousand year period
and this is laid throughout history to
the concept that there is a great week
of time where each day represents a
thousand years this is not a new concept
it's a very ancient concept and 1,000
years for the millennium then
presupposes that the other days will
also be one thousand year days so the
problem that people have with the
lecture is the date for the close of the
six thousand years hmm as I said my
crime was that I happened to add four
plus two and came to six which is a
problem so what is the problem with the
date we have to ask ourselves what is
the problem with the date the problem
with the date is that people can think
that you have set a specific time now I
repeatedly said I am NOT making a
specific time I am NOT date setting
because the Lord can add to it and take
away from it that's his prerogative not
mine so how can I say this in the light
of what we've kissed us can I use this
study as a definitive in terms of time
or are there other factors that need to
be taken into consideration now I didn't
mention all of these things in the
lecture after all it was a two-hour
lecture and if we mention them now it'll
become a three-hour lecture I can the
Bible and the spirit of prophecy help us
in this regard I believe the answer is
yes
so we need to consider all the possible
permutations before we create an undue
anxiety or excitement and it's always
possible if you are saying the time is
short well short is a very relative term
but if you say for example according to
a simple calculation there is a specific
time when this period is over but we
cannot take it as definitive because it
can be added to or taken or taken away
from it's a difference when you use
prophetic time because you cannot take
away or put on to a perfectly time
prophetic stuff specific is fixed that
we will discuss that difference so here
are some of the statements from the
previous lecture and these comes from
the spirit of prophecy now people will
say why use the spirit of prophecy why
didn't you use the Bible well I didn't
use the Bible because I didn't feel it
was the forum to go through let's say
the calculations of Bishop Asha so what
I did was I used the spirit of prophecy
but we could have used the Bible and all
the previous people who studied it in
ancient times used the Bible so we'll
look at some of those things so this is
one of the statements is that the savior
of the world had no controversy with
Satan who was expelled from heaven
because he was no longer worthy of a
place there he who could influence the
angels of God against their supreme
ruler and against his son there loved'
commander and enlist their sympathy for
himself was capable of any deception and
then you have these statements for
thousand years he had been warring
against the government of garden at lost
none of his skill or power to tempt now
many of the statements are not
definitive in the spirit of prophecy so
when she talks about 6,000 year period
then it is a period of 6,000 years and
she can use it generally
it doesn't mean that it's absolutely
100% 6000 years in many cases and here's
another one that's very interesting
which we used in that lecture on the
Jordans Bank the boys from heaven
attended by the manifestation from the
excellent glory proclaimed Christ to be
the son of the eternal now we know when
that took place that was at the baptism
of Jesus Satan was to personally
encounter the head of the kingdom which
he came to overthrow if he failed he
knew that he was lost therefore the
power of his temptation was in
accordance with the greatness of the
object which he would lose or gain for
4000 years now we have a starting point
here ever since the declaration was made
to Adam that the seed of the woman
should crush or bruise the Serpent's
head he had been planning his manner of
attack now this is more of a definitive
statement we have a starting point and
we have an end point the starting point
is when the promise was made that the
Serpent's head should be bruised and the
end point is on Jordans banks at the
baptism of Jesus so this is more of a
definitive statement now some people
will say but she also says 4,000 years
to the birth of Christ or 4,000 years
and the crucifixion yes there are
statements like that so if you want to
calculate it like that that's fine but
this one is definitive and it has
something else about it as well which
makes it special in my opinion and I
think when is entitled to give an
opinion or what do you think I agree
okay so people have come to different
conclusions some have taken it from the
birth of Christ some have taken it from
the crucifixion I took it from the
baptism because of a definitive it's not
a statement so why is it important to me
that this title should be more
interesting than other dates well
because of the prophecy of Daniel when
the full
of time was come what does that mean God
sent forth his son to redeem them which
were under the law that we might receive
the adoption of sons Galatians 4 verse 4
and 5 so this is the plan of redemption
the Savior's coming was foretold in Eden
when Adam and Eve first heard the
promise they looked for its speedy
fulfillment what was this promise it
lets the serpent say it would be great
that's right
okay say they joyfully welcomed their
firstborn son hoping that he might be a
deliverer but the fulfillment of the
promise tarried and those who first
receive it died without the site from
the days of Enoch the promise was
repeated through patriarchs and prophets
keeping alive the hope of his appearing
and yet he came not the prophecy of
Daniel revealed the time of his Advent
eNOS now here again the time of his
Advent if you just read this statement
you could take it to be the butler
questions could you take it to be the
crucifixion probably not not from that
statement as one but not all rightly
interpreted the message century of the
century passed away the voices of the
prophets ceased the hand of the
oppressor was heavy upon Israel and many
were ready to explain the days of
prolonged and every vision faileth
executive twenty-two so what can I get
out of this the fullness of time was
from when from the time that Adam
received the promise and it was revealed
in Daniels prophecy so again we get to
27 ad so we have a very specific
prophetic statement that cannot be moved
it's time the statement when Adam and
Eve first heard the promise you can go
to the previous four thousand years
together and it equates to that one
exactly so in my opinion this is the
more prominent day
not the crucifixion this doesn't make it
a false prophet because she was talking
about the period of time and it doesn't
have to be absolute but in my opinion
these were quite absolute statements and
this one Daniel of course very absolute
so now let's just continue and see how
Jesus dealt with us mark 1:13 and he was
there in the wilderness
forty days and he went into the
wilderness immediately after the baptism
and that was the first stage so he went
into the Willian wilderness to be
tempted and to overcome where Adam had
failed and was with the wild beasts and
the angels ministered unto him
now after that was John was put in the
prison so this is 40 days later he comes
out of the desert and he is ready to
come later to preach and it's
interesting that he came out of the
wilderness experience and he was there
again and his ministry was starting and
some of the disciples that had followed
John the Baptist who went to Jesus
because John the Baptist had said behold
the lamb of God that taketh away the
sins of the world yes and he was saying
the time is fulfilled what time what
time it was thought 27 ad when he
started his ministry so he was referring
to prophetic time which was the prophecy
of Daniel yes there's no doubt about
that
that cannot be moved that is set in
stone so now some people were saying
well why did you use the spirit of
prophecy well the spirit of prophecy is
in harmony with a Bible right let's have
a look at the Bible the Bible revelation
chapter 10 takes us to the time of the
unsealing of the longest prophetic time
not
about cosmic week time which is which is
a literal time period in the Book of
Daniel the 2300 day prophecy after which
there would be no more prophetic time to
precisely predict when prophesied events
would take place however there would be
signs which the Watchmen on the walls
were to watch out for so if we go to
Revelation chapter 10 where this
prophecy is now being unsealed and I
swear by him that liveth for ever and
ever who created heaven and the things
that are therein and the earth and the
things that therein are and the sea and
the things which are therein it's
interesting that's the seal of God you
also find it in the heart of the fourth
commandment right that there should be
time no longer now if you took that
literally this would mean the time
stopped when that little book was
unsealed means there should be no more
time obviously that is not what it means
because time continued the clock
continued to think that would also mean
that the cosmic time would also still
continue to take arise so what does it
mean it means there will be no more
prophetic time but we are to watch for
the signs Matthew 24 verse 32 now learn
the parable of the fig tree when his
branch is yet tender and putteth forth
leaves you know that summer is nigh so
what is our job our job is to look at
the prophetic signs which was the first
half of the lecture saying we near don't
try and put it off for another hundred
years or two hundred years or a thousand
years or not in my lifetime well in my
case that wouldn't be too long because
I'm getting long in the tooth but this
is the bottom line there will be no more
prophetic time and there will be no more
time setting after that that doesn't
mean that the clock doesn't continue
next
we'll be 2021 whether we like it or not
right the clock will continue to take
but there will be no more prophetic time
what about okay we say no more prophetic
time but what is the when you talk now
about like there's a few prophecies that
still has to be fulfilled but it's not
hanging on time it's not hanging on
prophetic time you're correct there are
events that must take place but there is
no specific prophetic time when that
event will take place you will know that
it has happened when it takes place so
now the spirit of prophecy is also very
clear so the Bible says there will be no
more time prophetic time and she has the
same statements that there will be no
definite time after 1844 that doesn't
mean that the cosmic clock doesn't
continue to tick this it just means
there will be no specific time when you
can say this or that will take place so
let's have a look at some of these
statements our position has been one of
waiting and watching
with no time Proclamation to intervene
between the close of prophetic time in
so after 1844 which is the end of the
2300 day prophecy there is no more
prophetic time and I dealt with that in
the lecture I specifically dealt with it
I said there will be no more prophetic
time there are people that are using
prophetic time and trying to fit it into
the time periods that we are living in
that is not in accordance with the
scripture I clearly clearly stated this
in the lecture but that doesn't affect
cosmic time just like our time is also
still continuing and there can be no
definite time for the coming of Christ
not even in cosmic time even though
cosmic time will
us that next year will be 2021 whether
we like it or not if the time ends in
that doesn't mean Jesus is coming me it
doesn't mean that he's coming in 2027 it
means that according to a simple
calculation that is when the time will
be when the 6000 years are over but it
doesn't mean that Jesus will come then
and I made that abundantly clear but
people tend to misunderstand and we have
to therefore be very careful it's let's
look at it further so the people will
not have another message upon definite
time after this period of time
revelation 10 4 6 quoted here reaching
from 1842 to 1844 there can be no
definite tracing of the prophetic time
the longest reckoning reached to the
autumns of 1844 that's where prophetic
time ends any attempt to manipulate
those prophecies or take time periods
out of those time prophecies and make
them actual time or not in harmony with
Scripture most of if not all that quotes
that Ellen White had on not setting a
date or time refer to prophetic time
refers to prophetic time it's very clear
so we mustn't confuse the issue here's
another one this time which the angel
declares where the solemn earth is not
the end of the world's history time
carries on news
neither of probationary time it carries
on but of prophetic time we have to make
this point very clear which would
precede the advent of the Lord that is
the people will not have another message
upon definite time what you're talking
about now no prophetic time this is the
context after this period of time
referring to the prophetic time
reaching from 1842 to 1844 there can be
no definite tracing of the prophetic
time it's very clear the longest
reckoning reaches to the autumn of 1844
okay so the clock didn't stop ticking
there's no more prophetic time and we
cannot manipulate the prophecies to make
them say what we want them to sound
reapply them now we can again and again
I have been warned in regard to time
setting they will never again be a
message for the people of God that will
be based on time we are not to know the
definite time either of the outpouring
of the Holy Spirit or for the coming of
Christ we will not know when Christ is
going to come yes now we were receiving
messages that we had made a specific
time
now we had not because specifically I
said we cannot use this because can be
cut short or whatever or lengthened so
we're not sitting a specific time but
that doesn't mean that next year won't
be 2021 but the day and the hour of his
coming Christ has not revealed now this
is a phenomenal statement because
remember we had a document by James
white in the previous lecture where he
argued using some of the the best
informed theologians of the time that
when when the first said that no one
knows than the day or the hour but not
even the son knows the day in the hour
that that verse should actually read
make known yes now some people would say
they have a problem with that why should
it be make known but he being God must
know so some people thought well as God
he knew but as man he didn't know it
gets very confusing so let's have a look
this at this one this comes from the
desire of Ages there's a primary source
in the review
Harold so they're basically coming from
the same source when you're looking at
them but this is very interesting but
the day and the hour of his coming
Christ has not revealed he stated
plainly to his disciples that he himself
could not make known the day or the hour
she doesn't write didn't know of his
second appearing had he been at liberty
to reveal this why need he have exhorted
them to maintain an attitude of constant
expectancy now this is the important
thing we need an attitude of constant
expectancy we need to look at the signs
of the times and of course we need to
get our own hearts in harmony with God
there are those who claim to know the
very day and hour of our Lord's
appearing very earnest or they in
mapping out the future but the Lord has
want them off the ground they occupy the
exact time of the second coming of the
Son of Man is God's mystery now if you
look at the historic context in which
this is portrayed the wedding of Christ
to his bride the consummation when he
comes to fetch his bride now in the
ancient times when such a wedding took
place it was not those that were being
married that announced the time it was
the father that had the privilege of
announcing the time so this is in
accordance with this this principle
that's very interesting to see our
history correlates with them but it's
very clear that he or she makes use of
the word make known yes just like James
white used it in his document and he
quoted the theologians of the day we are
not to live upon time excitement we are
not to be engrossed
speculation in regards to the times and
the seasons which God has not revealed
Jesus has told his disciples to watch
now that was the first half of the
lecture yes looking at the signs of the
times but not for a definite time his
followers are to be in the position of
those who are listening for the order of
their captain they are to watch wait
pray and work as they approach the time
for the coming of the Lord but no one
will be able to predict just when that
time will come but you will be able to
say it is near can you use everything in
your power to say it is near for that
day and hour knoweth no man you will not
be able to say that he will come in one
two or five years neither are you to put
off his coming by stating that it may
not be for ten or twenty years now
that's actually exactly what I did in
that lecture I said I don't know whether
it's gonna be one two three four or five
years I don't know it could be more it
could be even but I shouldn't given the
information that we have say that it
will be for ten twenty or thirty or or a
hundred or two hundred or even a
thousand years by giving the gospel to
the world it is in our power to hasten
our Lord's return now this was very
interesting we are not only to look for
but to hasten the coming of the the day
of God see second Peter 3 verse 12 had
the church done her appointed work as
the Lord ordained the whole world would
before this had been warned and Jesus
would have come now this is fascinating
so you can actually hasten the coming
you can shorten the time and by your
inactivity you can lengthen the time now
in saying this does that mean that God
will only come when the churches
it's duty well there are other
statements which say a time which God
has fixed and we do not know what their
time is so history of sin will not
continue indefinitely there are other
statements for example software which
talk about the number which he has fixed
when they have accepted the gospel I
don't want to go there because I cannot
know those things so here's another
important point when we talk about time
prophecy is conditional and predicting a
precise time can create despair in some
and rash actions in others now again
let's be very specific here you get
general prophecies if you do this this
and this then that and that will happen
take God's promises to Israel the
blessings and the cursings if you do
this and this and this and this this and
this and this will happen there's no
specific time attached to those but you
can't do that with the prophecy of
Daniel which has a specific time that is
cost in concrete and you cannot move it
so again prophecy about events or
conditional so let's have a look at some
biblical examples of conditional
prophecies and events the fall of
Nineveh and the preaching of Jonah Jonah
was probably petrified that it was going
to be a false prophet because he said
forty days in this place will be
destroyed yes and it never happened
why not because it was called a
conditional prophecy they repented and
because of it God postponed the
inevitable judgment wasn't any V
eventually destroyed yes yes when it
came to the point of non repentance so
there's a conditional prophecy so you
can you can actually say this and this
will happen then
doesn't happen the destruction of Sodom
and Gomorrah is now a counter situation
here there was a threat that it was
going to be destroyed and it was
destroyed and but Abraham interceded
right he interceded and eventually he
said you know what if there were 50
righteous people and God said I would
not destroy it and he whittled it down
what did they are ten righteous and then
he relented and it was destroyed so in
other words with God's knowledge it was
absolutely a fact that they weren't ten
or even five righteous people in Sodom
and it was destroyed so the conquest of
Canaan here again they could have
entered in when they first reached the
borders of Kalyan but because of
unbelief and because of the bad report
of the spies and those spies that were
giving a good report Joshua and Caleb
they were picking up stones to stun them
and so God sent them back into the
desert into the wilderness for forty
years so these are all conditional it
could have happened but it didn't happen
and then we also have a delay of 1888
for example when the first siege took
place and there were Sunday laws coming
in the United States of America had the
message gone out in its power as it
should have then Christ could have
returned and we would have cut 120 years
off we will look at some of those
statements later second Peter I just
want to say so if I in my if I can say
you've got the example of Sodom and
Gomorrah and you've got the delay of
1888 so similarly in the end we can add
the same exact we can say they the
church must be perfect before Christ
must come but if God knows beforehand
that this will not happen with for
instance then it will be like
Sodom and Gomorrah when a certain level
has come then a certain time that God
has fixed then that will be the end
second Peter 3 verse 9 the Lord is not
slack concerning his promise as some men
count slackness but is long-suffering to
us with not willing that any should
perish but that all should come to
repentance so some of us say why isn't
he come yet
well he's not slack but he is
long-suffering and he wants all to come
to repentance so it is not for me to say
when the Lord must come I can only look
at the signs and say that it is near so
I was not making a time in that
particular lecture
it was another aspect that came up
because of the lecture there is a fear
that the message will be brought into
disrepute or that the profit will be
brought into disrepute that a true
prophet must be in harmony with the
Bible right now if you in this day and
age want to get up and say that this
world is 6,000 years old and that the
cosmic week has come to an end your
church and you will be in disrepute
because they will say you've gone insane
this world is millions and billions of
years old so of course you're going to
be ridiculed when you say that and we'll
come to that but the Bible says in
Isaiah 8 verse 22 the lawn to the
testimony if they speak not according to
this word it is because there is no
light in them what does that mean well
that means that anything a prophet sees
must be in harmony with the Bible now
does the Bible say that this world is
about six thousand years old and if the
Bible says that this year is about six
thousand years old then the prophecy
that comes afterwards let's say in the
spirit of prophecy
they cannot exceed that because it must
be in harmony with the Bible so if the
Prophet would be coming into disrepute
because you're saying that the
6,000 years well then the Bible is also
in distributed yes so what is the Bible
teach that should be our next question
and by the way that was one of the
questions why did you use Ellen White
and why didn't you use the Bible so what
is the Bible teach and what did the
early church and the Reformers and the
pioneers of the seventh-day Adventist
Church believe regarding this issue and
now we're going to make a distinction
we're not talking about prophetic time
now we're talking about actual time
again let me make it abundantly clear
that even actual time is not going to be
a cleaving life that says this is the
limit because again the same applies the
Lord could have come earlier because you
can shorten the time by your action by
your preaching or you can delay he's
coming even if there is a clock that is
ticking it is still in God's power to
say whether he comes before that time or
even after that time it's not for me to
say that so the same applies but the
fact of the matter is a clock does tick
and next year we will celebrate a new
year and the year after that another new
year for however long it's still going
to tick right so what is the Bible teach
and now we're going to be in trouble
again because it depends what Bible you
use yes there is the Septuagint in the
Old Testament versus the Masoretic text
and the Masoretic text is the one that
is the Hebrew text and the Alex X which
is the Septuagint was the Alexandrian
version and it is a Greek text which
everybody supposes was around in the
time of Jesus
many suppose that Jesus actually quoted
from it so why are we so scared of this
cosmic time concept because if you look
at the early church fathers if you look
at the Pioneers if you look at many of
the reformers they believed it right now
why are we so scared of it and why
should we not speak of it except above a
whisper high criticism is one of the
reasons the Alex X the Septuagint is
another reason and the theory of
evolution is another reason after the
19th century when these things started
coming into the world
then those became serious issues so
today nobody wants to speak about the
cosmic week now I have a question for
the viewers and for you for that matter
is it a crime to speak about the cosmic
week not for me is it is it in history
yes are they clear statements in history
about it means must we wipe out the
history because it's not fashionable in
the times that we are living in no well
do we now also everybody else that said
it previously we just judged about it
now well let's have a look at it because
basically we didn't want to go there but
let's have a look at it higher criticism
higher criticism tends to rip the Bible
apart by putting everything into
question particularly when it comes to
the time issue I put the time issue in
the question and anyway if the
manuscripts don't agree in terms of the
time how do you know which time it is is
this the Word of God who is that the
Word of God now we have had that
discussion before many people are not
exactly charmed by discussion such as
those but to me it is very important
for me to know am i reading what God
said
or am i reading what people think God
said that is very important so let's
have a look at some of these issues
let's just go to the Septuagint here's a
book and by the way this is what the
book looks like it's a little book by
Martin Klein but they are there are so
many books on this issue that it boggles
the mind and you can just check it out
on the web pages too you can even you
can even download the Septuagint and you
can use translations of the subdue grant
into English if you don't want to read
it into Greek it's all available you can
read it so this little book called the
has magnified thy word above all thy
name by Martin Klein has a very short
little section on the SIPTU again and
I'm going to read it so that nobody will
be inclined to say that we are saying
this let us just see what what the
literature says so lately it is popular
to quote from or refer to the Septuagint
perhaps the speaker wants to sound
scholarly or maybe it is just because it
is the popular thing to do all most
likely the speaker is simply unaware of
the facts most people who really have no
idea what the Septuagint is and even
most Bible scholars or ignorant of many
salient details to begin with the name
Septuagint is short for the Latin title
versio Septuagint our interpreting
meaning translation of the 70
interpreters and abbreviated Alex X it
is a Greek translation of the Hebrew Old
Testament supposed to have been
translated around 295 to 250 BC in
Alexandria Egypt so it's an excellent
Sandri inversion according to the legend
translations were accomplished by 72
Jewish scholars 6 from each tribe
already this is a serious problem
because those who entrust it by God to
be the guardians of the scriptures we're
to be the Levites and the Levites alone
so how could the other tribes have been
involved and by the way by the time this
thing was written the other tribes were
gone already they'd already been
dispersed just the interesting
observation it's called the translation
of the seventy
but there's 72 Jewish scholars that
translated it so that's interesting
Jewish scholars six from each tribe and
in 72 days now that in itself is quite
incredible at the request of ptolemy ii
Philadelphus since greek was the trade
language of jesus' their scholars claim
that this is the Bible that Jesus used
and quoted from rather than the Hebrew
most of the details of the story come
from an ancient document called the
letter of Aristeas now I don't think we
have to go all the way through the
letter of Aristeas but the important
point is there are so many anomalies in
this letter the dates are wrong the
events are wrong that most scholars come
to the conclusion that this is a forged
letter to give authenticity to this
manuscript so there's these blunders
where he has the time periods wrong and
the Victory's wrong we don't have to go
into all of those details such
historical errors recorded in the letter
of Aristeas disclosed the undeniable
fact that the work is not of the time
period it claims surely enough has
already been said to alert the reader to
the true nature of Aristeas and then the
letter of Aristeas appears to have been
written about 150 years after the time
period it claims to be from and was
exposed as a legend and as early as 1705
by humphrey rd a Protestant professor of
Greek
Oxford 1698 279 ardently those scholars
agree that the letter is fiction most of
the details oft-repeated regarding the
origin of the set you can still come
from this letter it's amazing how it
works
so we've already discussed that it would
be unlikely that they would have people
from the other tribes being involved in
the 72 days is very problematic yes and
then the quality of the translation in
the Septuagint varies widely from the
from book to book from fairly good in
the Pentateuch to incompetent in the
Book of Isaiah and the Psalms are not
much better Esther job the proverbs are
not faithful translations and
paraphrases perhaps I can add there that
if you read the book of Esther in the
Septuagint there are so many
embellishments that it becomes
ridiculous completely ridiculous I mean
according to the Septuagint Esther sat
down and put ashes and done over herself
while she was in this period of mourning
before she went to the king and
apparently she cut all our locks of hair
of that there were all of our robes and
then she went to the king and she was
then beautifully dressed and looked
beautiful I don't know how she managed
that after all of that episode and then
according to the Septuagint she fainted
numerous times while she was in front of
the king and he ran and it's a
ridiculous story so obviously it it
doesn't have the the beauty of Scripture
so now here's the portion that that is
particularly relevant the Septuagint
contains many serious problems that we
could not accept as the faithful fully
preserved Word of God
the majority of Alex X manuscripts gives
hundred and sixty-seven as the age of
Methuselah at the birth of his son Lommy
the Hebrew reads 187 Genesis 5:25
however if
methuselah 167 at the birth of Lama Lama
188 at the birth of Noah and now a 600
at the flood as recorded in the Alex X
Methuselah would have been 909 955 at
the date of the flood and since he lived
to be 969 years old and that's the life
span given in both the Septuagint and
amezo heretic then the Alex comes up
with this entangled absurdity of making
Methuselah survive the flood by 14 years
but not only that if you go afterwards
all the ages are lengthened and there is
such a pattern to it that it becomes
nonsensical and the bottom line is that
the time is greatly prolonged in the
Septuagint so if you use those dates you
cannot possibly come to 6,000 years
you'll probably come to six thousand
seven hundred and something years just
using the genealogies yes so the the
author keel is telling us that the
Hebrew Old Testament is the only
reliable text and therefore the Alex X
and the Samaritan Pentateuch cannot be
trusted but in life
so which manuscript are you going to use
to determine the time period involved in
the Bible and the consensus of the best
scholars is that the Masoretic text is
the one that you should pass it on and
the the Bible's of the Protestant
Reformation use that text so that is the
one that you use not only that the
Septuagint is like the missing link in
evolution now I find this rather
interesting so everyone assumes it is
there somewhere but no one can seem to
find it
remember the Septuagint is supposed to
be a Greek translation of the Hebrew Old
Testament from around 250 BC that Jesus
quoted from when on earth so they say by
the way I don't believe it personally
I don't believe Jesus ever had a subdued
and in his hand I believe that Jesus
quoted the Hebrew Scriptures because
that was the Hebrew tradition the
Septuagint is supposed to be a Greek
translation of the Hebrew Testament from
around 250 that Jesus quoted from when I
know forever when someone quotes to you
from the Septuagint today they are
actually quoting from the Sinaiticus and
Vaticanus of the 4th century idea at the
earliest now why would someone quote
from a fourth century ID manuscript when
they could quote from a 250 BC
manuscript if all there is better
because they have not found the 250 BC
manuscript it is the mythical
predecessor to the Sinaiticus and
Vaticanus that everyone assumes is there
and no one can find so the Catholic
Church capitalized on the forged letter
of Aristeas and it's story of the
Septuagint to give validity to their
corrupted Greek manuscripts making them
sound as if there were copies of the
Bible that Jesus used essentially the
earliest Septuagint is the fifth column
of oregon's hexapla or six columns Bible
circa AD 245 so there is this column in
Oregon's six translation Bible and they
use that and say well this must be based
on something earlier and therefore this
is what it was now if you take Oregon
who was a Gnostic nice then you can
understand some of the embellishments
that you have in that particular
document so here are the people that
were involved in these manuscript Justin
Martin tatyana clement of alexandria
oregon Eusebius and oregon became the
head of the school of alexandra by ad
213 okay now what did he teach Oregon
taught that the soul existed from
eternity so Roman Catholicism would
would appreciate that right not only
that he also taught
what purgatory yes now that's
fascinating who would like that the
Bible knows nothing about purgatory but
Oregon thought it and then he must have
had other problems because he
emasculated himself so maybe he was
fighting the flesh I don't know what his
problem was
and Oregon said that the Scriptures are
of little use to those who understand
them as they are written and the spirit
of prophecy says read your Bible as it
stands so we have this conflict between
the people that think in terms of the
Gnostic mindset and those that believe
God as it stands now here's another very
interesting point and I are given
lectures on this before helena petrovna
blavatsky a Luciferian who established
the Theosophical society and is
considered to be the mother of modern
occultism agrees with oregon truly
unless we read the Old Testament
cabbalistic Lee and comprehend the
healing meaning thereof there is very
little that we can learn from it so the
Bible is actually a document that you
have to read cabbalistic Lee you don't
read what it says you read what you
infer between the lines that's now
according to blah blah - blah Watsky ah
not only this but levansky considered
the secure again and the Vulgate to be
correct and the Protestant Bible the
King James to be in error and that is a
modern concept today I hear it
everywhere that the very worst
manuscripts are the ones that the King
James is based on all that Martin Luther
based the Bibles on all the Geneva Bible
based it's version on so this is
fascinating to me this whole study and
of course the Septuagint is the basis of
many modern Bibles at least the Old
Testament portion but the influence even
stretches to the New Testament yes so
you have all of these lengths and times
and thus if you again and can you change
these times
one example that always tickles my
interest is Jesus is asked how many
times must I forgive my brother yes and
the answer that Jesus gives is seventy
times seven times now if you read the
modern translations like the NIV for
example it'll say 77 times now I did
Jesus say seventy times seven that's a
reference to Daniel chapter 9 because
the time of probation as a nation for
the Jews to herald the gospel was from
the issuing of the decree for seventy
times seven right and that is the
prophetic time period that probation as
a nation would grant them this special
status as the ones who were to proclaim
the gospel so how long must I forgive my
brother how many times until probation
closes that's what Jesus said yes if you
take the NIV it becomes just a useless
statement seventy-seven times okay you
if you bother me seventy seven times is
your limit now it makes no sense just
for interest sake how did the Reformers
see it did they use the time periods and
the Bible and I received an interesting
letter which which I didn't go into
details but it's just interesting the
Geneva Bible for example was written in
1516 and there's a detailed record of
the age of the earth from the time of
Adam to Noah Noah to Abraham Abraham
Israel in Egypt etc and by the time it
was 1560 how old had they calculated of
the earth to be and remember this is in
the time of the Reformation this is not
in the time of Ellen White great 1560
was the time of the Reformers and they
reckoned the earth then when this Bible
was written to be five hundred five
thousand five hundred
34 years and six months I don't know how
they got to that but anyway that's what
they said so this person fast forwarded
to 2020 to see how old would the earth
be in 2020 and came to the conclusion if
you add the time there that it would be
five thousand nine hundred ninety four
and when with the six thousand end and
there right would you would arrive at
2027 now this is just the Bible not the
spirit of prophecy at all it's just
coincidental it's just an interesting
point let's not make a great deal out of
it but let's look how the Reformers used
this time period or these time periods
the King James Version used the
chronology of James Asha the author of
the famous work the annals of the world
James Ussher was the Church of Ireland
Archbishop of Armagh and primate of All
Ireland between 1625 and 1656 so some of
the later versions would have footnotes
of Asha now Asha is not very well
accepted today in fact quite ridiculed
in some circles but he wasn't a very
thorough scholar and the calculations
that he made are the basis of many
Protestant thinkers ideas on the cosmic
week and some people believe that Ellen
White might have been influenced by
Ash's chronology in her statements but
her statements have nothing to do with
that they're very definitive statements
they do not like Asha give specific
dates for specific events for example
Asha will give the exact date of the
creation and he says it's 4004 BC etc
etc so let's not go there but the fact
of the matter is that the theologians of
the history of the world have used the
chronology of the Bible to determine
where we are in the stream of time it's
just a fact of history so how many of
the of the church
others for example believed in the
cosmic week of history so let's have a
look cosmic week and the Church Fathers
so here's an article in Wikipedia early
premillennialists included see da
Barnabas
papayas Methodius lactantius comedy
honest Theophilus Tertullian Malita he
Politis of rom Victorious of petal and
many of these theologians and others in
the early church expressed their belief
in premillennialism
in other words Christ returns and then
comes the Millennium rights through
their acceptance of the sexta scepter
millennial tradition or does that mean
this belief claims that human history
will continue for 6,000 years and then
we'll enjoy a Sabbath for 1000 years the
Millennial Kingdom thus all of human
history will have a total of 7,000 years
part prior to the new creation
that's just history so all of these
church fathers believed it let's have a
look at one or two of their statements
just to see what they believed
Irenaeus who lived 80 120 to 201 he
wrote for in as many days as this world
was made in so many thousand years shall
it be concluded and for this reason the
scripture says thus the heavens and the
earth were finished and all their
adornment and God brought to a
conclusion upon the sixth day the work
that he had made and God rested upon the
seventh day from all his work now this
is very important all of them linked
this time period to the creation week
and made the creation week a type of the
cosmic week yes so day 1 would be a
thousand years day to the next thousand
years etc day six the six thousand years
and then the millennial period this is
how they
or interpreted and they used many
scriptures in the Bible that they
interpreted only in the light of this
concept no this is totally gone in the
time that we are living in let's
continue with what he said so this is
now a church father this man has was not
influenced by the writings of lng white
because he had the Bible and Ellen White
didn't come for many many years later
this is an account of the things
formerly created as also it is a
prophecy of what is to come for the day
of the Lord is as a thousand years and
in six days created things were
completed it is evident therefore that
they will come to an end at the six
thousandth year the whole apostasy of
6,000 years and unrighteousness and
wickedness and false prophecy and
deception for which things sake a
cataclysm of fire shall come upon the
earth that's what he believed these are
to take place in the times of the
kingdom that is upon the seventh day
which has been sanctified in which God
rested from all the works which he
created which is the true sabbath of the
righteous which they shall not be
engaged in other earthly occupations but
shall have a table at hand prepared for
them by guards supplying them with all
sorts of dishes so he's referring to the
millennial period so Irenaeus believed
in the cosmic week 6,000 1,000 here's
another important one he Politis we're
not gonna go through all of them he
lived 80 170 to 236 and he wrote and six
thousand years must needs be
accomplished in order that the sabbath
may come the rest the holy day in which
God rested from all his works for the
Sabbath is the type see it was a type
and emblem of the future Kingdom of the
Saints when they shall reign with Christ
when he comes from heaven as John says
in his apocalypse for a day
where the Lord is as a thousand years
since then in six days God made all
things it follows that six thousand
years must be fulfilled that's what the
church fathers believed based on
Scripture alone now I want to know what
did the pioneers of the seventh-day
Adventist Church believe we know what
many of the reformers believed because
they included it in their footnotes
right so now let's have a look at some
of the pioneers of the seventh-day
Adventist Church and I know this should
not be spoken up and why not if I can
quote Irenaeus why can't I quote
Waggoner exactly would you have a
problem with that or never and the
Prophet John wrote the angel spoke thus
and God shall wipe away all tears from
their eyes and there shall be no more
death neither sorrow nor crying neither
shall there be any more pain for the
former things are passed away and he
that sat upon the throne said behold I
make all things new now this is a
reference again to the post millennium
restoration of all things
Eden is then fully restored here the
river of the waters of life floods from
Mount Zion here Adam regains the Tree of
Life planted beside the river which
parts in two separate heads as in the
beginning here again is paradise the
garden which the Lord Himself planted
seven thousand years before this is what
they believe here Abraham inherits the
earth according to the promise here is
the City for which he looked every
inhabitant of which regards him as a
father here Moses will enter into that
goodly land which he saw with the eyes
of a prophet he had David will behold
his throne established never more to be
overturned but to endure as the son even
as the days of heaven here is the chosen
company of those who were redeemed from
the earth at the
of the Lord who overcame the Beast and
His image and the mark of his name by
strict adherence to the commandments of
God and the faith of Jesus in the
perilous days when all the world was
overcome with the prevailing iniquity
clearly he believed in the cosmic week
Thomas pribyl and these book the two
atoms before the first atom had the
conflict with Satan in which he fell the
seventh day or Sabbath had passed so
with the second atom before the last and
final conflict with Satan and his hosts
and which eternal victory will be gained
for the Son of God and his people the
Sabbath or seven thousand years will be
passed I believed it
what about Joshua Hinds signs of the
times and the expositor of property the
world was created in six days see they
all like the early church fathers link
it to the creation week now what is
important to me in this is that you have
this unbelievable link with the sadder
yes and if the Sabbath is the fourth
commandment that prefigures a final rest
in a cosmic day of a thousand years then
the sabbath gains in prominence so this
cosmic week idea lifts the sabbath up
absolute status and we can understand
with more clarity why the sabbath will
be the issue at the end of the time yes
and and this is this is important to me
so the world was created in six days and
the seventh day god christed from his
labors six days shall you labor and do
all your work and then he quotes the
commandment and then whether Jews every
seventh day was a day of rest every
seventh year a year
restore jubilee 7 in the bible language
seems a complete number in six troubles
may quotes a verse I found this
fascinating in six troubles the Lord
will be with thee and support thee and
in the seventh there shall no evil
befall thee this distinction we see
carried out from the first chapter of
Genesis to the last of Revelation
seven thousand years have therefore
appeared to me as complete and I expect
after the six thousand years of labor
and toil perplexity and suffering the 7
thousandths will usher in the glorious
Jubilee and is this verse in John 5:19
he shall deliver thee in six troubles
yay in seven there shall no evil touch
thee and this this is how they used
these verses not in terms of literal but
in terms of cosmic time so in six
troubles that's the six thousand years
he will be with you and he will guide
you through these troubles times and in
seven there shall no evil touch thee in
other words in that millennium you will
be safe in his rest isn't that beautiful
beautiful it is beautiful I don't think
this verse can mean so much if you don't
read it in that context I I have the
exact same suspicion this is what Jay
Clarke wrote Advent review in Sabbath
Herald the Bible answers every query and
solves every doubt I like the way he
writes in this blessed book the lover of
history finds full information of past
and future events beginning with the
first Eden and reaching over a period of
seven thousand years to the second Eden
in the earth made new here the lover of
prophecy may be feasted with the words
of inspiration
and telling of scenes to come the future
history of our race and of the planet we
inhabit here's another one now I know I
am being tedious now but I think we need
to make a point and we need to make it
very strongly and I'll say in a moment
why I personally with my personal
experience feel very strongly about this
as well
Josiah leach had a lot to say about it
oh there were many I'm not quoting them
all no the most beloved preacher of the
Advent movement was Fitch and he
believed exactly the same thing so I
haven't quoted them all but this one I
find very interesting the first report
of the General Conference of Christians
expecting the advent of the Lord Jesus
Christ that means this whole crowd of
them right that's why I put it in they
all believed it
man was the last piece of divine
workmanship on creation week was
finished and a race of model agents
produced God rested the seventh day from
all his work which he had made this
coupling to the fourth commandment is a
theme that runs through this theology
and as I said the Church Fathers believe
this this comes from them all runs from
the time of Christ and you can virtually
say to today let us an attend to the use
the posture Paul makes of this act of
divine procedure for we which have
believed to enter into rest as he said
so what is he quoting he is quoting
Hebrews chapter 4 where Paul talks about
we have a Sabbath day but he's referring
to the rest that we will enter into
which is a reference to the millennial
race because a lot of people use that
same thing now to say that the Sabbath
is not we don't have to keep the Sabbath
it's because we've gone into race-tin
Jesus absolutely but this is a reference
to the
Kosmic millennial 1000 period your
period of risk so in other words and God
did rest the seventh day from all his
works he's quoting Paul the argument is
that although from the foundation of the
world a rest was provided for man yet
those and those only who believe shall
inherit it he also draws from the text
he quotes 3 inferences that God's rest
on the seventh day was typically
prophetic now this is interesting in
other words it wasn't a specific time
prophecy it was typically prophetic of a
future rest for his believing people so
it was based on literal time and not
based on prophetic time it was a type of
logical time setting and that the rest
which Joshua gave wasn't complete
therefore there remains the rest for the
people of God perhaps I ever it may be
objected
although the Sabbath is a type of the
future rest which remains for the people
of God yet it does not exactly follow
that it is a prophecy of it but let us
look at this point a type is an image
and representative of another and
subsequent object does not in the very
idea of a type presuppose the subsequent
existence of its anti-type it's a good
question unless it does it is no type at
all hence if the Sabbath is a type of a
futurist for God's people the
promulgation of that type is a prophecy
of the anti-type it follows therefore
that prophecy and prophecy of a futurist
for God's people began with the exercise
of God's moral government of a man the
seventh day from the beginning of
creation and to give the chronology of
prophecy is to trace its history from
period to period from its origin to its
consummation so let us enquire them more
particularly what the Sabbath prefigures
and predicts because it's this is the
issue of the end times and the seventh
day
this church has consistently said that
the Sabbath will be the issue and people
say who cares whether it's this day with
that day is it that important yeah
doesn't this add prominence to it oh
definitely so that it predicts a future
rest for God's people we have already
seen it has been an almost universal
opinion of the church both Jewish and
Christian that the Sabbath prefigures a
glorious state of rest for the church
during the seven thousand years of the
world here he says and again the
principle arguments in favor of this are
briefly as follows God made the world in
six days and rested the seventh and
constitute that the Sabbath a type of
future rest so we may expect that after
the troubles and commotions of 6000
years there will be a rest of a thousand
years from all these sorrows the
institution of the Sabbath and the
Jubilees among the Jews has been
considered typical of the same the third
argument is from 2nd Peter where he says
a days for a thousand years the fourth I
think is the strongest argument
it's from the 20th chapter of Revelation
where he talks about the thousand year
reign so if there is a specific time
period which refers to the rest the
millennium and there must be specific
time periods for the other ones that's
his argument psy concludes with this
with these remarks I will now proceed to
show that the chronology of prophecy is
recorded in the Bible presents us with
seven thousand years from the beginning
of the exercise of God's moral
government of a man to the final period
of the conquest of all God's enemies and
when Satan death and hell with all whose
names are not written in the book of
life will be cast into the lake of fire
which is the second death that's what
they believe here a couple of
interesting inferences Adam died on the
first day Genesis chapter 2 verse 17
reads this is how they thought I'm just
adding this for interest sake but all
the tree of the knowledge of the good of
me and evil thou shalt not
of it for the day that thou eatest
thereof thou shalt surely die
now everybody sit but Adam didn't die
yeah so how do you interpret this
well they say well he really did die
spiritually but he still carried on
living right now how these reformers or
these pioneers thought about it was that
he was referring to the cosmic day which
is a thousand days yes and so the day
that thou eatest thereof thou shalt
surely die did he die in the first
cosmic day the answer is yes in fact
none of the antediluvian reached a
thousand years in age they all died
before that so they all died within the
first cosmic day if you would like to
call it that or this verse of a year
they are 6 verse 1 & 2 come and let us
return unto the Lord for yes torn and he
will heal us he is smitten and he will
bind us up after two days will he revive
us in the third day he will raise us up
and we shall live in his sight many
would like to say that this is a
reference to the resurrection yes but
you could also as these people read it
say after two days he will revive us in
the third he will raise us up and we
shall live in his sights and so they
would say that there must be a two-day
cosmic day until Christ returns so that
must be 2,000 years and then will come
the Millenium yes the thousand two the
third day now let me talk a little bit
about my personal experience why was i
interested and i mentioned it in the
first lecture it's because of the
evolution creation debate why is it not
popular to speak about this issue why is
it that people are so passionate about
it that you should not raise your voice
above a whisper
you speak about these things the church
fathers believed it the Pioneers
believed it it's in disrepute we spoke
about why we mentioned the alux eggs and
Septuagint is one of the reasons the
highe critics who ridiculed the Bible
because it's not consistent playing one
manuscript against the other we don't
have to go that route we have to
determine there's that there's a true
line and there is a false line and we
stick to the true line that we don't
have to become confused by all of these
so-called contradictions and the third
point I mentioned was evolution correct
now when I came into this church I was
also involved in the debate as to
whether we in this day and age can
really believe that God created the
world in six days and I am happy to
report that this church confirmed that
we believe in a literal six-day creation
which is problematic in the world yes
but there's another issue that wasn't
addressed and that is how old is the
earth and there there were so many
opinions as there were people available
so I came into the world believing
millions of years and then I had to
suddenly get used to the the world was
created in six days it was impossible
for me and then I was supposed to keep a
Sabbath now if if a day represented the
thousand years well then the argument
was maybe he meant millions of years you
know but everything would have been out
of sync in the creation week for
everything's out of sync the plants
would come before the Sun is it going to
wait for millions of years for the Sun
to come to you know and the the the sea
mammals are in the ocean before the
mammals actually developed and come from
everything's out of sync so you either
have to totally discard what evolution
says if you want to marry them you have
serious problems and then the age issue
and the argument of course is always
radiometric dating perhaps you can put a
link in to some of those discussions on
radiometric dating as to why they are
not valid because they are based on
assumptions because they are always
based on a parent isotope which decays
into a daughter isotope and your
presupposition is always that the parent
isotope was the only one that was
present in Iraq and the daughter isotope
was not it there because it had to decay
into the daughter isotope so your
assumption is always there was only
parent no daughter so if you find lots
of daughter
then you must assume that it took
whatever the half-life is so many
millions of years to arrive at the
daughter but what if there was daughter
in the rock from the beginning every
other than the role was there why
shouldn't that one be there uranium lead
why must I assume there was only a
rhenium and no lead so the assumption
determines how old something is so it's
based on an assumption so can I say how
old the earth is no I cannot now in the
times of Darwin they didn't use
radiometric dating it hadn't been
invented so what did they have
they had child Lyle's observations and
they are not in accordance with what you
see because all the layers are flat so
there were all of these issues saying
finally I came to the conclusion that I
cannot use radiometric dating because
it's based on an assumption and your
assumption determines the outcome I
cannot use that Charles Lyell's idea is
not consistent with what I see what I
see and I went to all of the sites I
went on tour through the world to look
at these sites and what I found was
catastrophism and catastrophism does in
a short period
what uniformitarianism does over me
millions of years but this concept that
the world is ancient and old is so
installed and ingrained in the minds of
men that it's hard to shake it and then
there is the question of ridicule people
are afraid of ridicule and I was
listening to many of the lectures from
people from the faith and scientists
prominent scientists from the faith
giving lectures and saying yes but you
know all right maybe it's not billions
of years old but you know we can't say
6,000 degree it's so ridiculous so let
us say hundreds of thousands and you
have all of these compromised things
it's just unacceptable in the time that
we are living to say that the 6,000
years old yes and so I recall I went to
one of these lecturers professors and I
knew him from discussions and
what-have-you and I said to him or why
do you do this why do you do this why
are you saying hundreds of thousands of
years when the Bible says six thousand
years and everything is based older all
the criteria that we are using to
lengthen the time or based on
assumptions and science if properly
understood will show that the Bible is
true that everything had a watery demise
that there was a catastrophe a flood and
that the features that we see or as a
consequence of this catastrophe and not
of a long periods of time through
uniformitarian things why are you saying
a hundred thousand years and his answer
was because we will look ridiculous in
the sight of the scientific world and I
looked at him and I the sadness and I
see
you know what I come from the
evolutionary world I was an atheist I
was an evolutionist I taught evolution
at the universities if you're gonna say
the world is hundreds of thousands of
years old he had to be ridiculous in the
eyes of the scientific fraternity
because they say billions a hundred
thousand they're gonna say you're a fool
and if you say six thousand then
everybody else out there will say you're
a fool
but the Bible won't say you're a fool
and the spirit of prophecy won't say
you're a fool yes so there are two
chairs that you can choose to sit on you
can choose to sit on the evolutionary
chair and you can choose to sit on God's
chair and in both cases you will have
opposition yes so why do you choose to
sit between two chairs and be a fool in
the eyes of God and a fool in the eyes
of the world why not sit on one of them
choose God's chair and be a friend of
God and take the ridicule of the world
but fall between two chairs why do you
want to do that so I there decided that
I will sit on the chair of Scripture God
said it I'm going to believe it
because all the evidence I have points
to it I have decided for me personally
that I have no problem with the earth
that is 6,000 years old so I would have
no problem with the cosmic week to it I
wouldn't have a problem if anybody else
has a problem that's fine you don't have
to believe the cosmic week I'm not
telling anyone to believe the cosmic
week I'm just saying I would have no
problem believing it I'm not even saying
I believe it I'm just saying I would
have no problem believing it so this is
how they use the text so let's just go
again to this one one fear is that
quoting the spirit of prophecy on the
cosmic week is not in accordance with
modern thinking as if this could
discredit the spirit of prophecy
because we look ridiculous in the eyes
of the world right you say who listen
people are mad are you a fundamentalist
you believe the world is 6,000 years
well then good grief then you might as
well believe anything right that the
moon is made of cheese
if the Bible contains this concept on
the other hand then any true prophet
would have to be in harmony with it
isn't that swell yes so then it cannot
be an issue that discredits the Prophet
on the contrary if the Bible says 6000
and all the church fathers believed it
if a prophet comes and says it's not
6000 then who is being discredited now
yes
exactly the Bible rive rait and the
sabbath is a type of the final rest
we've discovered that beautiful so
Ezekiel chapter 20 verse 12 says
moreover also I gave them my Sabbath's
to be a sign between me and them that
they may know that i am the lord that
sanctified them the third angel's
message
what is that in tyre several have
written to me inquiring if a message of
justification by faith is the third
angel's message and I have answered it
is the third angel's message in rarity
this message was to bring more
prominently before the world uplifted
Savior the sacrifice for sins of the
whole world it presented justification
through faith in surety it invited the
people to receive the righteousness of
Christ which is made manifest in
obedience to all of God's commandments
so when we preach the three angels
messages today and we say do not accept
the mark of the beast
do not accept the false Sabbath which
doesn't give you an accurate record of
what God did that he created you and
that he redeemed you yes it contains the
message do not accept a false
commandment but why because he's the one
that sanctified you he's the one that
created you he has the one that has the
power
negative to tell you what the truth is
and by keeping the Sabbath you are
literally saying to the world I believe
what God said that's what you're doing
and you're accepting his authority in
your life so they will say to me you
mean to believe you believe that God
created the world in six days and on the
seventh day he rested and I will say yes
and they will say you're a fool there
was the world was not created in six
days it took millions and millions of
years and I say I'm sorry I'm sitting on
a chair where I believe God rather than
science in this particular case right
yes you get into trouble so now when we
preach this are we then saying that
Christ is coming in a particular day or
in a particular one some have yes and
are we saying that the the three angels
message cannot stand on its own by
talking about the cosmic week a cosmic
week is a separate issue
it's what the Reformers believe it's
what the church fathers believed it's a
separate issue it is a typology that's
running in the background but it doesn't
mean that the time that it predicts is
going to be the exact time when Christ
is going to come because we cannot
predict that sex act time if anything it
must create a fire under the preachers
of a third three angels nation
absolutely because then you know that we
are not only dealing with cosmic time we
are also dealing with science and we
must look at them both the some have
been in our store refusing to put on the
wedding garment they still wear their
citizens dress and despise the garments
woven in the loom of heaven which is
Christ our righteousness why is Christ
not come yet we can ask ourselves
because we could have hastened the time
right and he said unto me write blessed
are they which are called unto the
marriage supper of the lamb who are
friends of Christ today
now who are friends of Christ today do
you feel an intense desire for the robe
of Christ's righteousness are you
sensible of the filthy rags of your own
righteousness then let the truth come
into your practical life if your friends
of Christ show it in words in spirit
manifest love to Jesus and love for the
souls for whom he has died
the sentiments of truth are the elements
that constitute a symmetrical Christian
character we are far far from being
Christians which is to be christ-like we
need the Holy Spirit's efficiency God
lives and reigns the very reason that
the Holy Spirit's manifestations were
not accepted as precious tokens from God
is that there was not a receiving of the
grace of God the Spirit of the Lord has
been upon his messengers whom he has
sent with light precious life but there
were so many who had turned their face
away from the Sun of righteousness that
they saw not it's bright beams the Lord
says of them they are turned their backs
to me and not the face there is need of
seeking the Lord earnestly we are living
in a time when we need to seek the Lord
earnestly there was a time when a
message went out in 1998 that we have to
accept the righteousness of Christ the
law of God is the standard of character
and you can have a righteousness of
works trying to live up to the standard
or you can find the robe of
righteousness of Christ and we didn't
enter in in 1998 because we had the
wrong cost concept the history of
ancient Israel is a striking
illustration of the past experience of
the Adventist body God led his people in
the Advent movement even as he led the
children of Israel from Egypt in the
great disappointment their faith was
tested as was that of the Hebrews at the
Red Sea had they trusted to the guiding
hand that had been
with them in their past experience they
would have seen of the salvation of God
if all who had labored unitedly in the
work in 1844 had received the third
angels message and proclaimed it in the
power of the Holy Spirit proclaiming the
righteousness of Christ to keep God's
law not because you are saved by your
works but because you have accepted the
righteousness of Christ if all Andres
unitedly in the work in 18:4 had
received the third angel's message and
proclaimed it in the power of the Holy
Spirit the Lord would have wrought
mightily with their efforts a flood of
life would have been shed upon the world
years ago the inhabitants of the earth
would have been warned the closing were
completed and Christ would have come for
the redemption of his people this is the
bottom line if we did a simple
calculation just as in the Geneva Bible
and using the spirit of prophecy came up
with a time when the 6,000 years should
be ended that does not mean in any shape
or form
that that is the cutoff date because you
can hasten the coming of the Lord and
the Lord can lengthen the days it's not
for me to say whether he comes in the
first watch or the second watch there
were people that answered and sent those
quotes like a hammer saying that we are
transgressing now we were quoting
history and making a simple calculation
but that doesn't mean that that is the
end of the world and people should
understand that
our hope is based on Revelation chapter
22 verse 20 and it says he who testifies
of these things say yes I am coming soon
amen
come Lord Jesus the aim of that lecture
was to say time is short the signs of
the times are screaming at us
time is short
that even the cosmic week if we believe
what the Bible says and what the spirit
of prophecy says irrespective of whether
you want to calculate it from this date
or that it's irrelevant the point is the
time is short even that period is coming
to an end
which God can lengthen because He is God
and God can shorten as we have seen
because he is God
but to say that there are nothing there
are no signs and it can still be a
hundred years Oh until the Lord comes oh
it may never happen because the church
is you know not ready then you are like
like Graham and Catholicism and you say
that you're an anal aeneas the
millennium is not coming and then all
the saints will be in the grave forever
and ever and ever and that is not
biblical so what we were saying is the
time is short don't put words into the
mouth that weren't said it was
repeatedly it was stated and yes we know
all the other statements as well
and we have quoted them but I don't
believe we did that in the first lecture
I hope this clarifies the issue I
thought that quickly came to me one of
the reasons you took the 2780 you've
showed and for me personally what I got
out of that one is that Satan confronted
Jesus in the wilderness and where Adam
didn't succeed in Eden Jesus succeeded
in the wilderness yes so he his victory
over Satan and sin was they absolutely
and he paid for the sins of the world at
the cross so that's why for me that made
a lot of things for me peace so again if
people want to differ I want to find a
different time period that's their
prerogative nobody's going to argue with
it and is it going to change it by a lot
of time no it's not going to change it
so that's not the point
the
point is the time is shackled just a
final issue that also cropped up was
that people must interpret it what you
said and I can encourage them to look
again at the lecture from one hour 38
minutes is that the cutoff time that you
mentioned that Ellen White was
describing when they will be gathering
the weapons and doing better as will be
probably cut off from the six thousand
year period and added that at the time
that's cut off here will be added again
at the end of the thousand-year
millennium of peace to make up the six
thousand years ago yes that probably
complicated things for some people it
was a supposition and I think it is in
my opinion a fairly logical supposition
that if he has six thousand years and
again let me reiterate we do not know
exactly in God's providence whether he
will lengthen it or shorten that so let
me not go there again but at a time
period of his transgression period he's
warring against God it takes place after
the Millennium because he creates an
army and I was just suggesting that that
time period could be cut off from before
and added to the end so that the total
time that he was against God is then six
thousand years isn't bringing the
conclusion to seven thousand cannot more
than seven thousand and lace guard
decide unless God decides to limit the
time which is his perfect right one
final issue before we end this
discussion his people will say well if
this so little time I might as well give
up I'm not gonna give you ready we are
taught that our righteousness is the
righteousness of Christ how long did it
take the thief on the cross to receive
the righteousness of
first did he have years to get his life
in order no he had just his
contemplative time on the cross that's
it and so anyone who feels threatened by
the idea that Jesus is coming very soon
then follow the example of the thief and
say to the Lord Lord I am a sinner and
I've transgressed your law and I have no
right to heaven but if you clothed me
with your righteousness then I will
stand before you as though I had never
sinned confess your sins and repent and
God will take you through the time that
we are living in and bring you into that
glorious rest which is called the
Sabbath of rest may the Lord bless you
all
let us close in prayer Heavenly Father
what a magnificent story is recorded in
your Bible a story of pain a story of
woe a story of great sacrifice the
greatest sacrifice of all is the
sacrifice of the Son of God and because
of that sacrifice we all have access to
the throne of God help everyone who is
listening to embrace it to say Lord
close us with your righteousness remove
our filthy rags and give us access to
your rest in Jesus name Amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click yes when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time